hi I'm Claudia ashrae this is my new
friend Mark schoenwetter and we are here
to celebrate Hanukkah spread a little
light and talk to Mark about his amazing
journey hi Mark how are you
so far I'm doing good are you scared of
me a little bit
you look very handsome today
oh my God keep you can you talk on this
subject all the time yes so tell me
about your sweater where is it from
five and ten stunning isn't it it's
stunning yeah it's a really big honor
for me to talk to you I think um it's
such a huge privilege to be come from a
generation where we have survivors who
we can talk to and learn from and I
think a lot of young people are feeling
um a little scared about the state of
the world right now for Jews obviously
with social media tick tock
anti-Semitism and just hate in general
spreads a lot faster but can you talk
about when you were coming up it
obviously didn't happen like that there
was no Tick Tock
um tell me about what what that was like
the the start of the hate and how you
knew things were getting bad
well I started getting
the knowledge how things are getting bad
when I was a little child and the
Germans invaded pollen and conquered
Poland his start
eliminating the Jewish people
but then I start seeing
how bad it starts getting
and of course during the Holocaust for
this whole period of time
then I got the knowledge how bad could
it be
and when that was happening obviously
you went through enormous tragedy you
were hidden by other families in Poland
and your values and your Traditions were
put on hold and now you're here in
America and we're celebrating Hanukkah
and I'm curious if you have any memories
of celebrating Hanukkah Before the War
and what those Traditions were like well
honestly I have to say that I do not
have any memory
of any basically Jewish holidays before
the war before the Holocaust when it
started
because there was no time for me to
learn
because we had to escape and hide during
this whole period of time and how old
were you when the war started six six
and can you talk a little bit about you
know part of your story is other
families in Poland taking you in and I'm
curious if you are in contact with those
people and just in general what what
that was like
well
the few people that helped us during
this period of time in particular two
families
one was the family of diwat and the
other one was family of judges
and just quickly saying how they did
help us for example Mr P watt helped us
escape from our little village
and he took us to ghetto
because he felt that would be the safest
place to be
and
he later came and took us out from the
ghetto
told us how to escape helped us to
escape
and took us to a village
to a farmer that
took us in and hide us forever not long
time but enough for a whole one winter
that we survived and the other family
was the judges family again
that was so good to us that in case we
couldn't fight during the winter any
other place
to hide somewhere this was a place that
we could come in and they would keep us
for a week or two but unfortunately they
were afraid we had to go and look around
someplace else
and in particularly my mom kept in touch
with them
as long as she was alive oh wow that's
amazing yes and so when you say us who
were you with at that time in my younger
sister there were three of us hiding
during this whole period of time mom
my little sister and me and your mom
stayed in contact with the family yeah
long after yes have you been back to
Poland do you find it too difficult
well I've been back to Poland several
times after I left Poland
it was
honestly it was very nice it was
very excited to go because I want to
take first I want to take my kids and
show them where I came from
then I want to take my grandkids one day
were able to travel already and they
went to polling with me
and then we went again once because they
renew the cemetery in our little village
and then again I went to Poland
because they found the grave where my
father was killed wow and not only him
but there were another 250.
men women and children that were killed
so I did go several times to Poland how
many grandchildren do you have well I
have
four grandkids one daughter has two
girls
and the other one has two boys that's
amazing it's nice what do you do on
Hanukkah with them
well we I created this tradition
when they were ready little older
that we all have to make
plot kiss potato pancakes yeah delicious
delicious so good and I say my are the
best
what do you put on it applesauce
I don't you don't no I like to eat them
the way they are are you against
applesauce in general or just when it
comes to latkes
oh yeah I like sauce you know applesauce
whatever but somehow this looks good and
to the tradition when we used to be at
before I came to United States
and we made Hanukkah when we were
together with Mom and this we used to
make the potato latkes and put them into
chicken soup oh
that's nice and it was so good I'm sure
it sounds so good
So speaking of your grandkids I think
the statistic is around 70 of gen Z
Generation Z doesn't know about the Six
Million Jews who perished in the
Holocaust and I'm curious what your take
on that is
well my take on it is very simple
that we not educating the young
Generations
to have the knowledge
what happened in those times
we let them forget Maybe
and the most important thing is
that in particular the Young Generation
should keep this in mind and be
knowledgeable
so maybe maybe
will never happen this again yeah
and what's your what do you want your
main takeaway to be because you know
it's a huge privilege for me to sit here
with you and I've met survivors in the
past and I recognize how much of a
privilege that is and how that won't
always be the case and I'm curious if
you have a takeaway you want to impart
onto the younger generation when it
comes to all that you've been through
well besides knowing
what I went through with my mom and my
sister and the ones
who went through regardless if this
wasn't a concentration camp
or hiding somewhere the dogs people the
Young Generation even if the older
generation
is aware of what happened at this period
of time
more knowledge they have
there is more possibility
that if God forbid anything like it
somebody will try to do it
they will have some opponents to it some
people knowledge
try to stop
and I always say
I don't want us to be a war between one
and the other
so if we teach the young Generations
that we don't want to live in hatred and
we don't want to create hatreds between
us
then maybe we will avoid the hatred yeah
you know you seem like a very happy guy
when I walked in here you had this big
smile your daughter's here
um how do you what is like how do you
see the world you know I think you've
seen more and been through more than
most people ever will and you still have
this like wonderful Radiance about you
how how do you do that
well
I give all this credit to my mom
and I tell you why
because during this period of time that
we were hiding
and you know two little kids
hungry dirty
everything everything
whatever could be bad it was
in every time
when we hungry
we cried
mom always had excuse with a smile
with the Hope giving us that will be
better don't worry
when we were hiding in the forest
and it was raining we were wet
we cried it's cold
we went mom was saying this is not so
bad
you know it's going to be sunny soon
you take your clothes you hang them on a
tree they will dry out then you say you
have clothes and they fine every little
thing she had the
positive Auto Gunner keep us always
not crying not complaining right that's
why I
got this from her
and I feel look I survived why shouldn't
I be happy true
and so now that you're a parent did you
take that sort of energy that she had
when it came to raising your own kids
definitely yeah same thing
I tried make always my kids look forward
with happiness
and be positive on things
don't cry don't fight between
friends or days
keep always friendship with everybody
because that's the only way
to live yeah and then when you were
raising your kids what kind of Gift
Giver were you did you give them a lot
of presents one every day one for all
eight days what did you do on Hanukkah
but
usually an Hanukkah and my tradition
would as little as I knew about the
holidays whatever I knew later
I used to always give him a few pennies
Anika guilt as they say right
that was a gift and this I'm not a big
Gift Giver are you a big gift receiver
no no no honestly no no what do you want
for Hanukkah this year
you see you got me here is there
something you want
um no no no no no
I accept as it is make potato latkins be
with the family enjoy it and that's the
best thing nothing better than that
nothing better like a Chanel bag for
Hanukkah
so I feel
um very privileged to have gone to
Jewish Day School and learn about the
Holocaust and even in Middle School have
the opportunity to meet with survivors
and have lunch with them and then
eventually go to Poland when I was in
the 12th grade it was a very difficult
trip I think in a lot of ways we were a
little young but also there's no there's
no perfect time to learn about what
happened there
um and to be honest some of my my most
fond memories from growing up was the
privilege of meeting survivors and now
that I do this for a living and I meet
so many people who aren't Jewish or have
never even met a Jew I feel like the
importance of you telling your story is
tenfold I'm sure you don't want to wake
up every day and relive the tragedies
but I know you know how um
sadly not only are these stories
dwindling but so many people don't know
about them and it and it makes me sad I
can't even imagine how
um upsetting that must be for you
it is upsetting that people don't know
that's why I always say
that everybody should be educated about
that and we have knowledge about it
because that's the only way if we know
what's going on will never maybe happen
again it's one of the things
and then
too bad when you went to Poland we
didn't know each other I know we could
have synced up this we will go yes you
see
and I do think um it's uh really popular
right now there are a lot of books that
become very popular and trendy whether
it's historical fiction or true stories
about the Holocaust I think movies are a
great great way to learn I watched you
know all the movies growing up and while
I think it's when I think back on how
young I was watching it I think I'm like
oh man why was I watching that movie but
I do think it ingrained in me like a
really
serious level of empathy and thirst for
knowledge when it comes to
um learning about the Holocaust and I
think those movies are great for someone
who didn't have the privilege like me of
going to Jewish Day School going to
Poland learning going vashem and while
those Journeys are are difficult I do
think that they're really important
especially for young people because then
when you look around and things are in
disarray and I think it feels for a lot
of the Jewish Community like the
anti-Semitism is just like more and more
and more and it doesn't stop I think you
realize how much more important it is to
learn that and I'm sure that's something
that when you were raising kids and and
grandchildren they were so honored to
have you in their life to teach him
about it and then also to share with
their friends
you were a popular guy
well you were right you were one thing
right here
that I did devoted my time from
the minute the I mean say
a minute you needed some time
dude tell him
about the survival of mine
because
if they would know
how can I live without telling them that
right
and you know speaking of Hanukkah I'm
curious if you have a similar story so
for me when we were younger I'm one of
four girls and we would light in order
of um oldest to youngest so I wouldn't
get to light until the third and then
the
seventh night and it kind of stung
because like I was a little bored
waiting for everyone I'm like hurry up I
could do this better
um and so but when I think back on that
like how lucky I am to have grown up
with those sorts of traditions and I
don't think people would even realize it
until everything is taken away from them
like it was when you were a kid how
important those Traditions are
that I agree with your thousand plus
another hundred because I say the
traditions
are the most important things
and then you see your grandkids and it
must bring you so much joy so much joy
yes what do they call you what's your
name Grandpa granny Gramps
happy happy that's a good one only Papi
that's nice I like that one
can you walk me through the Journey of
going from you know a young boy the war
has ended you're living in Poland to
then the man you are now you have a
family you have grandchildren a business
you're a mogul
um in America what was that Journey like
how did you get here
well when we lived in Poland
after the war we lived in Poland till
1957.
so
we got some experience living under the
communist regime
how was that
well depends
now you can I can say at night
it was
good and it was bad right
good because we were had freedom
we didn't have to hide anymore
regardless we didn't understand
what communism is
so it was good because we live it wasn't
the Nazis that was not the Nazis exactly
but it was tough a little bit because
you have to be careful what you said and
what you did because
maybe wouldn't go to a concentration
camp the way right but you could be
punished for it
but anyway
we left Poland because at one point the
Polish government
permit the Jewish people
if they be approved by the government
to leave Poland and the only one place
they will let them go
is to Israel
so my mom applied for the
papers to leave pollen they checked us
of course and they approve us
and we went to Israel
and then
it was a little difficult at those days
in Israel because
undeveloped the country was and
it was hard to get a job in so far so I
was talking to my mom and
I would like to go to America how old
were you I was at that time early 20s
already
so
mom had a couple three sisters and a
brother here which came in 1920 18.
so anyway we ask and they sent papers
for me
and I immigrated to United States by
myself wow I went by myself I went on a
boat and I came to America
and of course when I got here
it was difficult because I didn't speak
one word of English right I didn't have
any money now excuse me mom gave me five
dollars on it
so that was my money here so bad
I was staying with my
aunt
but then she says you have to get a job
of course
I couldn't get a job because I didn't
speak English nobody want to give me a
job
but finally
there were
this
three
that was my father with two son and
son-in-law they had the factory my
cousin knew him and asked him they can
give a job for a
someone that is also from Poland and
they were from Poland
so anyway they interview me they gave me
a job
when I came in I started working I
didn't know anything
because when I came here
in Poland I was a student in the in law
school I was at the University
my sister was in the university and
medical school so we came to Israel she
went to medical school but I had to go
to work to make a living
so when I came here I didn't have a
trade nothing right
so when I came to work what was my first
job they gave me a broom and a shovel
sweep the floors keep the place clean
and that's how I start working there and
I learned slowly
the trade it happened to be a Jewelry
Factory
so I start slowly
working and I
became
of the five years the manager in this
place
and then I had the opportunity
the one guy was retiring that had a
little Factory I knew him
I bought this place from him and I went
on my own
and I start my own business and I was
over 40 years
in the business of manufacturing wedding
rings and engagement rings oh that's so
nice yeah what do you think
do you walk into a room and Survey
everyone's jewelry now
yeah
yeah okay what do you think like I have
some crazy earrings like you like it
it's not too much
gorgeous you want them I I looked at
that yeah that's amazing and so you came
directly to New York from Israel I came
to New York and I went like my cousin
which I didn't know him he didn't know
me and I was scared because I got off
the boat I come to this big room and I
don't know what to do with myself where
to go I I don't know even how to ask
anybody right
but he was what end was smart enough ask
I sent a picture of myself so I sent a
picture so then he comes to me shows me
a picture I say well it's me
how did you learn English at at work at
work
so that's how I came to the United
States and
and how did you meet your wife
oh that's a tough one you're giving me
here that's a shame to say
just simply saying quick
a friend of mine I used to have which
came from Israel here to a Polish guy
too
we we visited each other he lived in
bedok in Queens I live in New Jersey and
it's Wednesday on Sundays we visited
each other one time he came in and he
liked the bread
he ate a piece of bread he said it's
good bread here so I said let's go to
Baker and buy a bread so we went to the
bakery
we brought the bread in
the girl who is taking the money
the cashier is a young girl
and we start making jokes in Polish
about the girl you know comments
in Paulie so how can she understand I
don't know
so when we were walking down she says
you know don't take for granted that
nobody else knows this language
wow
we didn't feel too comfortable after all
the comments we were making
and that was the beginning when I met
her and later on I moved to
I looked for a house the wolf from my
little upstairs in the one family house
I lived on the attic there almost
so I got my little money already so I
looked for an apartment
and I got a room
and who is living in the same house with
her parents oh my god let's be shared
it's a bit shared yes that's so nice I
love that and that's how it begins
Perfect story fairy tale
great thank you we killed a pound
nice
um can we take some pictures
you have your celebrity smile on